this right now covid 19 fueled flight
cancellations taking a toll on that
holiday travel and leaving many stranded
tis the season for the hustle and bustle
of holiday travel
people from all across the country were
rushing to their final destinations this
christmas eve at harry reid
international airport the only thing
they waited for was luggage so it's been
smooth those we spoke with friday night
say they didn't run into any problems an
arrival and departure boards only showed
a handful of delays and cancellations i
arrived like two hours early and i
didn't need to but that's not the case
everywhere as airlines around the world
canceled over 2 000 christmas eve
flights some 600 here in the u.s when
they came on at 4 00 a.m this morning
the lady told me i couldn't get out
until 4 59 this afternoon united delta
and other major carriers say the fast
spreading omicron variant has led to
staff shortages
this as tsa officials cite a
pre-pandemic level surge in airport
passengers we're doing our socially
distant you know following all the
guidelines so we're not worried at all
regardless those here at home say health
concerns and potential delays didn't
stop them from traveling this year he
tried to stay away from people we had to
sit next to them anyways it didn't
really matter and they encourage others
to take every precaution they can to
stay safe in 2022 it's important to get
vaccinated and get your boosters
both delta and united say they are
working to rebook passengers stuck at
airports all across the country delta's
ceo has asked the cdc to reduce the
quarantine time for anyone vaccinated